Yes, we've done a lot of stuff about
error correction in the past but it's
been in a fairly crude way. You might
remember we did a cube, with two good
codes on and some correction points
around it and all that. That was fine we
had it like majority voting - you know -
the correct things you could
receive were either three 0s or three
1s. So [if] you get 011. What do
you do? Well majority voting says it must
be the 111 option, but in doing
that we didn't take account of *where* the
1s were in the code. There was no
weighting as to whether the ones are on
the left or at the tail end on the right.
I mean 101 would have been just the same,
you see, two 1s and one 0. And a lot of
what we're going to talk about today is
very simply this: is if you look at your
bit-pattern as having mathematical
structure underneath it and being powers
of 2. Or that the positioning of the
things in the pattern matters. That's
what we're going to find is the way to
developing more powerful codes and one
very good way actually to show that and
you've all seen these is to use an example
it's not based on modulo 2 it's based
on dividing by 11.  [The] International Standard
Book Numbers [ISBNs] . Eleven is a prime number and,
believe me, by looking at those digits in
the ISBN number - but weighting them
according to their position - it means
that if one of them gets clobbered
- preferably not more than one - then you
can say: "I can work out what it must have
been". Not by majority voting but by
saying "Ah! it's damaged, and I know but
it's at position 6 counting from the left".
That's the secret.
This is a system based on the prime
number eleven. Now prime numbers as we
know are completely magic because every
time you divide something into them
it won't divide - because prime numbers
don't have factors! So, you divide 3
into 11 and you get "three 3s are 9
remainder 2". You divide 5s into
11, you get "two 5s are 10, remainder 1"
So, by dividing every
number less than 11, into 11, you generate
all the possible remainders. don't you?
You might have a remainder of 0, if
it really is 11. You might have a
remainder of 1, 2, 3, 4...  So, everything from
0 to 10 is a possible remainder of
trying to divide things into [or by] 11.
Mathematicians like to formalize
everything and give wonderful names. And
once you've learnt about them of course
you can show off fearfully in the pub -
until put in your place by a proper
mathematician - and say that you know what
a 'field' is. Well, I'm going to be talking
about integers but including 0 at the
bottom end. All the positive [integer] numbers 0 1
2 3 .... potentially going on for ever.
Right, what can we do with those integers? Can
we add them?  Yes.
Can we subtract them - can we take one
from the other?
Yes. Can we multiply - that's not too much
of a problem. And of course in the
infinite set of integers you can do all
of these things but the one thing you
can't do reliably is divide. Because
if [for example] you do 5/3
it's not an integer! So, divide is a
problem, because very often you send
yourself on a magical mystery tour
outside the field of integers. And you
end up with a real number! So, what you can say,
then, is that if you want to play around
with these things you really do need to
be able to do all four [operations]. But you'd like to
be able to do all 4 things but still
stay within integer numbers.
How can you rule out getting things like
3/5 or 1/7 and stuff like that?
How can you focus in on those integer
divisions and make them always yield
something back in the original set? And
this comes out quite happily - so long as
you're using primes - with modular
arithmetic. So, OK then,
let's take not the infinite set of
primes plus zero, let's just do it - because
ISBN works like this - modulo 11.
Suppose we say we want to add
7 plus 6, modulo 11. In other words it's
13 mod 11 and the rule is when you say
'modulo 11' it means you divide 11 into it
take the remainder. 13 modulo 11 is of
course 2. So it turns out for prime numbers
like 11 where you can generate every
remainder from 0 up to 10 it's dead
easy to do. Certainly dead easy to do 'add'
[and] 'subtract' because you just get, like,
clocks. You're, like, going around the circle,
except it's an 11-position clock, not a
12-position clock. And everything is
absolutely hunky-dory. It works just fine
for 'add' and 'subtract' and even 'multiply'.
But, OK then, how does ... [whispers] how can
you 'divide'? And does it work? And the answer
is: "yes, you can make it work", but only if
it's a prime number you're using as your
base of everything. And so what we ...
and this is relevant to understanding
ISBNs, believe me. What you need
to be able to do is to say: "I want to be
able for any two integers that I'm
looking at in here, to do 'a divided by b' ".
And I want a meaningful answer and I
want an answer to come out in the
range 0 - 10. How can I arrange to
do that? Well, the answer is to say that
'a divided by b' is the same as a - and I'm
going to use dot for multiply, OK?
Now would you agree with that?  'a divided by b'
is the same thing as 'a multiplied by 1/b'.
OK, so when you multiply out it's
a/b. So what the problem comes down
to, then, is: " ...  can you find the inverse of any
number"?  What does that mean?
Well, yes you can.
Let's take some number x in the range 1
to 11. Actually the range [is] 1 to 10 because
it's just the remainders that you can
get, if you see what I mean. For every one
of these things I want to find a
meaningful inverse, so that when x and
1/x are multiplied together they will
make 1, modulo this 11 thing. Well, if
you've got the number 1 it is its own
inverse. That's dead easy. OK, but you've
got 2. How would you do 1/2 ?  Well
the answer is - looking back at this thing
where it's 'a'  times '1/b',  we are
trying to find that. We're saying what
for the given 'a' what can we multiply it
by such that when we work it out, modulo
11, it will yield a remainder of 2 ?
[correction: a remainder of 1]
Think about it. If I put in 6 here I'm
gonna multiply and then divide by 11.
6 x 2 [is] 12. Divide by 11?
>> Sean: It's gonna be 1 remainder ...
>> DFB: That's what you want! You want
a remainder of 1. We got a remainder
of 1 - out of 2 - by multiplying it by 6 to
make it 12 then dividing by 11. That's a
remainder of 1. But that's the definition
of the inverse, right? We're trying to
find '1/b' and by definition 'b' times
'1/b'is going to come to be 1.
These are all the possible remainders
that you have in modulo-11 arithmetic.
If you say: "Well, I've got 2 but what's
the something to multiply 2 by such that when I
divide by 11, in the end, it comes out to
be to be 1 ?".  6 * 2 = 12;  12 / 11 goes once
remainder 1. So it's the `remainder 1' that matters.
What about 3? How would we turn 3 into being 12?
>> Sean: How do you turn 3 into being 12 ?
>> DFB: what do you multiply it by?
>> Sean: 4 ?
>> DFB: Yep! so do you agree that if you
multiply 3 by 4 you get 12?
Divide it by 11 - it's got a remainder of 1.
We're inverting things you see.  The
remainder is 1. How do you turn 4 into 12?
>> Sean: 3
>> DFB: 3. Well, of course, you see this property
straight away: if 3 inverts as 4 then 4 inverts as 3.
Ah! now come on: 5.  How can you turn 5 into
12?  You can't.
>> Sean: So, you've got to go higher?
>> DFB: Yes!
>> Sean: Right - so you go to what ... ?
>> DFB: You've got to make it be one more
than a multiple of 11.
>> Sean: [calculating] 25, 30, 35, 45 ... is
that too far?  If we got to 45 that would have a
remainder of 1, wouldn't it?
>> DFB: It would indeed! So how many 5s
are there in 45?
>> Sean: 9.
>> DFB: Sean, You're an undiscovered maths genius, mate!
Look at that! That's it! It says 9 *  5s are 45 works!
Because if you divide back by 11
4 * 11s are 44 - remainder 1.
It's the remainder 1 you want.  to know that you've
inverted it correctly. Next one:
how do you make 6 work?
>> Sean: Well, we'll invert a 2 ?
>> DFB: Yes, exactly. You have done [it]. If 2 becomes 6
[then] 6 becomes 2.  [What about] 7 ?
>> Sean: [calculates] 14, 21, 28, 35, 42, 49, 56
>> DFB: This one's quite a tough one. Keep going!
Seven eights are 56 but if you divide that by
the 11 it goes 5.  5 * 11 = 55 remainder 1. So the
answer there is 7 goes to 8. [So] 8 goes
to 7. What about 9?
>> Sean: Yes, 9 has got to be 5, right?
>> DFB: Yes 9 has got to be 5, because 5 was 9 .
And 10?  That's its own inverse.
Because 10 into 11 ? It goes once
remainder 1. What you're saying is that
there is a way to find the inverse of
something, so therefore you can do
division within a finite field.
And it will work so long as it's a prime.
>> Sean: so, at the moment because I'm just trying to
tie this back into the computer science
angle.  Would this be connected to
making sure your program can actually do
what it's being asked to do?
>> DFB: it's connected to being able, using this
kind of structures, to muck about with
the codes that you allocate to something
and depending on the nature of the
remainders and are the remainders correct
then you can do error correction. If the
remainder of something or other you've
done doesn't come to be 0, something's
gone wrong.
And this is all part and parcel of it. I think
the easiest way now in is to say:
"Do you really need this for ISBN?"
Yes, you do. [The]  first thing to remember about
ISBN is the publishers who use
them put arbitrary hyphens in for their
own purposes. You don't need to bother
about the hyphens, as far as the maths is
concerned! Now,  what I'm going to do here
is instead of doing one that works
straight away, I'm going to put one here
where I'm just using x to mean "I can't
read that digit - it's been printed badly".
[Or] they put a tick mark there, that can't
be right; Oh no! they put a square black
blob in there, I don't know what the heck ...
it's just got damaged. Can we put the
damage right and like I say, don't worry
at all about the hyphens.
I think 0 means it's English language
and then every publisher has a two digit
code of their own, and all that kind of stuff.
So here it is but the way that this
works, and is just an example of using an
underlying structure, this does not mean
I mean ... well, how many things do we have
here? 10, 11 digits? I mean, it's not
twenty billion or anything like that
reading left to right. It doesn't ... it's
not powers of 10 [that] it's based on. You go
from the left and you, basically, say this
has a weight of 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 ...
5 has a weight of 7; 8, 9, 10
OK -so what we now do is we say there's a
0 with a weight of 1. [So] 1 * 0
plus the 2 with a weight of 2, plus
0 with a weight of 3, plus 1 with
a weight of 4, plus 1 with a weight
of 5, plus x with a weight of 6.
x [is] the digit we don't know.
Plus 7 * 5, plus 8 * 0 plus 9 * 2, plus 10 * 7.
Due to earlier pre-calculation I can tell
you that when you add all that up, and
you take the answer modulo 11, you will
end up with 6x + 4, And we know that
if an International Standard Book Number
is correct, then you do this weighted
addition. You take it modulo eleven and
the answer will be 0, if it hasn't been
damaged. Well, this has been damaged we
don't know what x is so we can say
straight away 6x + 4 must equal 0,
to make it right modulo 11. So, what you
have to say then is 6x = -4, so
x = -4/6 (all modulo 11) so
what does -4 mean? Well, you look about
what you have to do with that to make it
work modulo 11 [click back 4 notches on
the modulo-11 clockface on screen]
It's 7. OK,  so this is the
same as 7 * 6 ^ (-1).
Now, don't you dare tell me you don't need to
be able to invert integers even to do an
ISBN! Remember we did all that inversion
table thing and if I can look back on to
my previous sheet, 1 / 6 is 2 (mod 11)
7 * 2 = 14, divided by 11 it gives
you the 3. So, x = 3.
>> Sean: Going back to that original
equation there 6x * 4, so that
would be 18 + 4, which is 22 which
is basically 11.
>> DFB: Oh yes yes!
Divided by it,  it's two, goes twice
remainder 0.  Yeah, thanks for that.
That's the way to check it out. It does come
to 22 which is exactly divisible by 11.
The remainder is zero.
End of story. It's now correct. So here was
a wonderful example, really - although it
came later than other developments - of
how just putting some structure on the
digits and saying: "Oh! it's not only just
that it's x - it's in position, you know,
position number 6 counting from one
from the left, and by giving a different
weighting to the integers, according to
where they are in the left-to-right
sequence. Even at the very least it will
tell you if an error has occurred. If
you just interchange two digits - which
is a classic thing to get wrong - if you
swap over two digits then the weights
become wrong, compared to what it should
be, and it won't have a remainder of 0
any more. This situation we're doing here
it will detect an error but it can't
correct it - unless you know where the
problem place is, that you're not sure
about. Well, we do know where the problem
place is that we're not sure about!. It's at
the 6th position counting from the left
and we knew it had been clobbered! So,
you can correct so long as you know
which position it is that that has been
clobbered. Technically, this is known in
the coding theory trade as an 'erasure'.
What it means is that the proper value has
been clobbered. Basically we can wrap up
now and say: "Well, more or less, we're well
on the way to finding the answer. You can
put structures on modulo certain prime
numbers and you can do the most amazing
recovery tricks!" And it's all down to
prime numbers. But then you say: "Well this
stuff about being able to
divide - being able to invert things. Does
that only work with finite fields at the
prime numbers. Not quite. There is a let-out
clause which is wonderful.
Which makes life heaven
for Coding Theorists and indeed for
Computer Scientists. It comes something
like this:  it's saying prime numbers
certainly work - will always work. Can you
do any better? An undiscovered genius in
1820 - long before Babbage was even doing the
Analytical Engine - was looking at all
this stuff saying: "Could I find a meaningful
inverse for something
that's not a prime, but is almost like a
prime?" And after much work this guy - very
sad - he got himself shot in a duel.
Pistols at Dawn. Evariste Galois. And what
he said was: "I can make this work and
find you an inverse, not just for primes
but for anything that's a *power* of a
prime. I'm not gonna call that an ordinary
field I'm going to call it a 'Galois Field' ".
So just think: "What's the smallest
possible real prime - no!  not real prime! -
'genuine prime'. Two! In the old days - the really
old days - one would have  thought: "Well, two's prime
but that's all you can do ... You can't do
anything else with it because it's .... Galois said 'No -
any power of two I can
make it be magic. 2 cubed; 2  to the fourth
any positive integer power of two. And
computer scientists, not yet born, if
they'd been there in 1820, you would
have said: "Oh right so  can use a whole byte!
I can use 2 ^8 . Yeah?!
Ad you'll find me an inverse and all that?
Yes! yes! yes! yes! yes!
And of course real mathematicians  say: "Boring!
boring! you know - computer scienctists
obsessing about powers of two. But it is
magic. Because it doesn't matter whether
you're taking hex nibbles, 2 to the power
4, whether you're taking bytes as you
commonly want to do. You can have your
byte as being your  unit of currency' and
instead of it not working - because it's
an even number - you can make it work
using Galois techniques  because it's a *power*
of 2. So that, really, is the baseline
knowledge you need. Because Reed-Solomon
codes and everything. They're done in
computers, they involve powers of 2.
2^8 th is 256. It can be made to work
but at the expense of an enormous amount
of modular arithmetic to do inverses on
everything from 0 to 255. Using
Galois techniques you end up with great
tables. Instead of just saying: modulo q, where q is a power
[correction: where q is a prime] Galois said: I am
now letting you have q = p ^ h. Of course
the prime on its won is a special case.
That's p ^ 1. Yeah? So p ^h,
where h is any integer power.
Wonderful, but like I say the expense
that comes in with this is  huge, huge,
huge amounts of modular arithmetic beinng
done on very large numbers. But we have
computers! Do we care? With this paradise
opened up to us now
Galois is saying: " I can make any power of
2 work. And I can give you a
multiplicative inverse - which is what you
want to make all your calculations work
correctly in this closed space". And you
say: "Well even for 2 ^ 8 = 256
and we're using a byte?" Yes, yes
that works fine! There's a lot of it.  this
leads to Reed-Solomon codes for CD error
correction. It also leads to QR codes
which are just stuck on everything now. They
use methods involving this sort of
manipulation. Like a scuff on a QR code
- can you recover from it? - and an even bigger scuff
on a CD.
>> Sean: Yeah I think we need to look at
a CD. Are you gonna get one out of the car?
>> DFB: I think that's a good idea. Right - hey
ho - this is gonna sort out ... oh dear! I wonder
what age group who are gonna love this:
"The Very Best of Little Feat" :-)